We must have a starting point from which to conduct our investigation.
Sometimes, this will be highly specified and
may even come to you from a colleague or perhaps a supervisor.
Often however, we start with vague direction we want to investigate.
And it is our job to refine this into something we can answer.
Let's start by asking the high-level question,
how popular were the different kinds of candy?
Note that this question can not be answered in the way that it is phrased.
We have no meaningful description of popular.
Much less a way to say that one candy is more popular than another.
To get the iterations analysis going, our task is to
refine this initial question until it is cast in the form of a precise,
statistical inference problem.
To do this, we will first need to make a guess as to how to quantify popularity.
So how would you quantify popularity?
What metrics would you use?
Type your answer in the text below.
Don't worry, there are no right or wrong answers.
And I will share my answer with you in the next video.